david is derived from the hebrew word  for beloved and according to urban  dictionary is a formidable foe to normal  people sometimes David likes to go by  dave dave was adopted the Star of David  is a symbol for Judaism David was the  king of Israel he was also the king of  scotland twice he was born in jackson  mississippi used to have 12 fingers  picked on me in the middle school and  started doing stand-up at the age of 17  he was once a radio talk show weatherman  has mad chops on the sex and has two  hearts David is a sex addict he  practices transcendental meditation and  his last name is really Jones David his  half Korean runs a CrossFit gym and has  two cats Edith in Ohio David was the  best thing about the movie prometheus  he's a famous singer in Germany annie  has a pretty sweet ride David is in  Panama California Kentucky and Nebraska  david has his own camp he's a work of  art and a best friend thanks David or  Dave whatever it is you go by these days